- Des images qui donnent
froid dans le dos : celles
d'une centrale nucléaire touchée
par des nts russes.
Située à Enerdohar, dans
le centre du pays, il s'agit
de la plus grande d'Europe.
Les tirs ont provoqué
un incendie, qui a
finalement été maîtrisé.
Un danger nucléaire a rapidement
été écarté; la sécurité du site
est maintenant garantie.
Le président Zelensky accuse
Moscou d'avoir recours
à la terreur nucléaire.
Au neuvième jour de
l'offensive russe, la liste
de villes bombardées s'allonge.
À Tchernihiv, au nord de
l'Ukraine, des tirs ont tuéplus.
Les attaques, qui visaient
des zones résidentielles,
se poursuivent aujourd'hui.
À Kherson, la plus grandelus ge
municipalité prise par
les Russes, les gens se massent
devant les supermarchés pour
acheter de la nourriture.
Mais un peu partout au pays,
les biens de première nécessité
se font de plus en plus rare;
les tablettes se vident
graduellement.
À Ode portuaire
plus à l'ouest, les civils
préparent des sacs de sable
dans l'espoir de repousser
l'arrivée des troupes.
Selon l'armée ukrainienne,
des navires russes
s'y dirigent; il s'agit
d'une cible stratégique.
Aux abords de Kiev,
l'artillerie russe a réduit
en cendraison.
Son propriétaire, impuissant,
la regarde partir en fumée.
"Nous n'avons entendu
qu'un se feu, puis
la moitié de la maison a été
détruite", explique Yevgen.
"C'est une bonne chose que
nos enfants soient sortis
juste avant. S'ils avaient été
dans l'autre pièce ça aurait été
la fin pour eux", raconte-t-il,
la gorge nouée.
Du côté russe, la liberté
de presse continue d'être mal. n
serre sérieusement la vis
aux citoyens et journalistes.
Toute personne qui diffuse des
informations jugéeèresèresèresès
sur l'armée s'exposent désormais
à 15 ans de prison.
Presque aussitôt,
de grands médias internationaux,
comme la BBC et Ra,
ont annoncé la suspension de
leurs activités journalistiques
dans le pays.
- Les gens sont arrêtés sous nos
yeux, montés dans des autobus.
Ici Aimée Lemieux,
Radio-Canada, M